that's it good to talk to you you got
some good news this morning from the
supreme power absolutely Trish good to
talk to you as well we're we're very
pleased justice was served we expected
to win but it certainly feels good to
win as decisively as we did what does
mean for the company I mean investors
certainly like it stocks trading higher
what does this mean for you as you move
forward no you know it all it means is
that we continue to get paid for our
content we will continue to do that as
we look forward we've already said we're
going to get received two billion
dollars by 2020 and retransmission fees
and all that's important here is that
broadcasters and cable content top of
you and everyone who is involved with
the content producing business get gets
paid appropriately to their content and
that somebody can't come and take that
content charge for it and not pay us
back for that contest so it's a it's a
very good day for our future what would
you have done had the court not ruled in
your favor I mean what was the other
card you could have played here if
things had not gone as you anticipated
Trish there were a lot of things we said
we we had the possibility of doing we
weren't we weren't going to die or roll
over and play dead but the good news is
we don't have to do that we had other
alternatives but we don't have to do any
of them we don't have to deal with any
of them you know the the other
alternatives were feasible and we
wouldn't have been hurt drastically but
this is a good victory for us and as I
said for our future so that the future
areas don't come along and say we can we
can steal content from the network I
mean it's a it's a good question when
you think about the future you know less
there's so much technological change
that's happening right now do you think
that laws need to be strengthened does
more need to be done to anticipate
future areas now you know what the truth
of the matter is area try to present a
case that we were against cloud our
content being in the cloud nothing could
be further from the truth we have
changed drastically how we're delivering
content to our public it's now going
through satellite that's going through
telephone companies it's going online
through companies like Netflix so we are
long no company like CBS would be as
successful as it is without being
technologically advanced and
technologically savvy what this was what
area was doing was not about technology
it was about set yes it was a new
technology and there will be others
right now because of the Supreme Court
ruling people will have to pay for our
content and you will be able to get it
in a variety of different ways and
that's what's exciting crust you know
let's let me read for you an excerpt
from the aerial comment the company is
saying that today's decision by the
United States Supreme Court is a massive
setback for the American consumer they
said today's decision clearly states
that how the technology works does not
matter and that this sends a chilling
message to the technology industry what
message do you think this decision is
sent by the detectives state it's a
massive setback for Ariel and Aereo only
once again their argument in front of
the Supreme Court was truly to mislead
the court into thinking that we were
going to be hurting consumers what the
consumer now gets is the highest quality
programming which cost us a lot of money
to produce and they will continue to get
that they will continue to get that what
area was doing was basically taking our
technology and selling it to the
consumer is that appropriate know the
people that produce the content are the
people who should be able to deliver the
content to the American public it
shouldn't be done by an illegal third
party let's talk briefly about
transmission fees how much money do you
think you're going to be able to make
and some of these retransmission fees
and you know being paid for your content
as we move forward down the road right
now the system is very simple you know
the cable companies pay us
retransmission fees and then they give
the public our content the same with
telcos and satellite companies and a
variety of sources online will be coming
to deliver our product to the American
consumer once again they have to come to
us to get the license for that to do
that so as a result we will continue to
deliver to the American consumer the NFL
NCIS the big bang theory
CBS Evening News 60 minutes etc that's
what this is about having people license
or content and us delivering the content
to the consumer so this is very Pro
consumer